Est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé
pourquoi la musique sonne juste ?
Ou bien au contraire peut sonner faux si, par exemple,
on joue sur un instrument qui est désaccordé ?
Et pourquoi il n'y a que 12 notes de musique
et pas euh, 9, 17 ou bien 42 ?
Est-ce que 12, c'est juste un choix arbitraire, culturel ?
Eh bien non, la question du nombre de notes et de
la manière dont on accorde les instruments sont liées.
Et pour le comprendre, on va construire la musique
en repartant de zéro et en fabriquant
nous-mêmes les notes dont on a besoin.
On va voir que tout repose sur la physique des instruments
mais aussi sur une égalité mathématique incroyable,
3^12 = 2^19 .
Alors en fait non, si vous êtes un peu matheux,
vous savez que cette égalité ne peut pas être vraie.
Une puissance de 3 ne peut pas être égale
à une puissance de 2, mais elle est presque vraie
et c'est ce presque qui cause tant d'ennuis
aux musiciens depuis des siècles.
Pour m'aider à reconstituer cette histoire musicale,
j'ai demandé à Vled Tapas,
de la chaîne "Le Set Barré", de venir m'aider un peu.
Salut Vled, tu nous présentes ta chaîne ?
Salut David, alors oui, c'est dans mes cordes.
Ah Ah, c'est drôle parce que, et bien,
il y a des instruments à cordes... hum...
Donc, "Le Set Barré", c'est la chaîne d'un musicologue
passionné par son boulot et par le jeu vidéo.
C'est moi...
J'y fait pas mal d'analyses de thèmes vidéoludiques,
mais aussi des vidéos sur des sujets musicaux
un peu plus généraux.
Par exemple dernièrement, j'ai sorti
une nouvelle série qui parle de la voix,
vu qu'il s'agit de mon instrument principal et que je l'enseigne.
et puis sur cette chaîne, je fais de la musique aussi, plein,
parce que je serais super triste
si j'étudiais la musique sans la pratiquer.
Et voilà !
Alors, allez vous abonner à sa chaîne et maintenant
que les présentations sont faites, on peut y aller.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Commençons par la base physique.
Le son, ce sont des ondes de vibration de l'air
qui peuvent être créées soit par un objets qui bouge,
par exemple une corde,
soit par de l'air qui rentre en résonance,
par exemple dans un tuyau d'orgue.
La hauteur du son, le fait qu'il soit aigu ou grave,
est liée à la fréquence de cette vibration
qu'on mesure en Hertz (Hz).
Quand la fréquence est faible, le son est grave
♪ [Son qui monte en fréquence] ♪
et plus la fréquence est élevée, plus le son sera aigu.
Si on prend une corde tendue,
par exemple une corde de guitare,
la fréquence de vibration va dépendre du diamètre
de la corde, de sa longueur et de sa tension
et donc, en jouant sur ces paramètres,
on peut produire des sons à la fréquence qu'on veut.
♪ [Son de guitare] ♪
Imaginons que la musique n'existe pas,
qu'il n'y ait pas d'instrument, pas de notes,
pas de Do Ré Mi Fa Sol, rien du tout.
Est-ce qu'on peut créer un instrument qui sonne bien
juste à partir de principes physiques ?
Et bien, on va essayer.
Supposons qu'on ait juste une seule corde tendue
ou bien un seul tuyau d'orgue, si vous voulez
qui produise un son à une certaine fréquence.
On va prendre ce son comme base
et pour la suite, peu importe cette fréquence de départ,
ce que je vais raconter va fonctionner,
mais pour simplifier les calculs, on va imaginer
que cette fréquence de départ, c'est 440Hz.
Ceux qui connaissent la musique savent peut-être que
cette fréquence, c'est ce qu'on appelle normalement un "La",
mais on a dit qu'on allait repartir de zéro
et oublier toutes ces conventions,
donc cette note, on va simplement l'appeler note N°1.
Voilà, j'ai un instrument avec une note,
ça va être dur de faire de la musique avec ça,
alors comment je fais pour créer d'autres notes ?
Et bien, on va partir de principes physiques.
Quand un objet vibre ou bien qu'une cavité résonne
avec une certaine fréquence F,
il vibre aussi naturellement toujours un peu
à la fréquence double, 2F,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la seconde harmonique.
Donc notre corde initiale qui vibre à 440Hz,
elle produit aussi naturellement un peu de son à 880Hz.
Donc si on ajoute à notre instrument
une corde supplémentaire faite pour vibrer à 880Hz,
cette nouvelle note sonnera bien
avec la première qu'on avait déjà.
Cette harmonie entre les deux notes va aussi fonctionner
avec d'autres systèmes de production du son.
On peut regarder, par exemple,
ce que ça donne avec un tuyau d'orgue
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Ça sonne bien, non ?
C'est parce qu'il y a un principe physique
qui fait que ça fonctionne
et ça sonne même tellement bien que pour notre
cerveau, ces deux notes c'est quasiment la même.
On dit que la deuxième note c'est l'octave de la première.
Mais cette nouvelle note,
on peut à son tour doubler sa fréquence
pour obtenir une note de fréquence
qui est le quadruple de celle de départ,
qui sonnera bien aussi avec les 2 autres.
Puis à nouveau, pour obtenir 8 fois la fréquence, etc...
Et Inversement, on peut aussi diviser
la fréquence de départ par 2,
et oui, si une note sonne harmonieusement
avec sa fréquence double,
notre 440Hz de départ sonnera
aussi bien avec sa moitié, 220Hz
et aussi son quart, 110Hz, etc...
Et voilà, on a construit plein de nouvelles notes
pour notre instrument
et comme ces notes sonnent toutes à peu près pareil,
on va collectivement les appeler notes N°1.
Alors, ça c'est très bien, mais faire de la musique
avec un seule note, même sur différentes octaves,
ça va être quand même assez chiant.
♪ [Musique] ♪
Est-ce qu'on peut faire mieux
et enrichir un peu notre instrument ?
Et bien oui, on peut et on va à nouveau
faire appel à des principes physiques.
♪ [Générique] ♪
On a vu qu'un objet qui produit du son à la fréquence F
produit aussi naturellement du son à la fréquence 2F
et bien pour les mêmes raisons, il va aussi
un petit peu vibrer à la fréquence 3F,
qu'on appelle la 3ème harmonique.
En repartant de notre note de départ, 440Hz,
la fréquence 3F c'est 1320Hz.
C'est une nouvelle note qu'on n'avait pas jusqu'ici
et donc on peut la rajouter à notre instrument.
Ecoutez ça, c'est vraiment une note qui est différente de la note N°1,
mais qui sonne harmonieusement à nos oreilles.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Cette nouvelle note, on va l'appeler note N°2
et on dit que c'est la quinte de la note N°1.
On peut à son tour lui appliquer
le principe des octaves
et créer de nouvelles fréquences
en divisant et en multipliant par 2.
En particulier, en divisant 1320 par 2, on obtient 660Hz
qui est une note qui est plus proche
de notre note de départ
et au final, on obtient le lien
entre les deux en multipliant par 3/2
et les deux sonnent bien ensemble, donc.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
On a maintenant 2 notes
vraiment différentes sur notre instrument
et pour aller plus loin, on peut simplement
appliquer le principe de la quinte à la note N°2
et créer comme ça, la note N°3.
Si on multiplie la fréquence de la note N°2
par 3/2, on obtient 990Hz
on peut, comme toujours, multiplier ou diviser par 2
pour faire les octaves de cette nouvelle note
et en particulier, on passe de 660Hz à 495Hz
en multipliant par 3/4.
Grâce au principe des octaves, passer d'une note à
une autre en multipliant par 3, 3/2 ou 3/4 revient au même,
donc je fais l'un ou l'autre quand ça m'arrange.
Pour créer encore plein
de nouvelles notes à mon instrument,
on n'a plus qu'à répéter ce principe
de passage à la quinte.
La note N°3 a été obtenue comme la quinte de la note N°2,
ensuite on construit la note N°4
comme quinte de la note N°3
puis la N°5, la N°6, etc...
C'est super, on a maintenant plein
de nouvelles notes pour notre instrument
et qui sont basées sur un principe physique qui assure
que chaque note va bien sonner avec sa quinte.
Mais du coup, on fait ça indéfiniment,
on rajoute des notes à l'infini ?
Et bien non, parce qu'un véritable miracle se produit.
Quand on fait ça pour la 12ème fois,
on retombe sur des fréquences qui sont
très proches de notre note de départ.
Regardez là et là.
Ça veut dire que la quinte de la note N°12,
celle qu'on aurait envie d'appeler, la note N°13,
c'est quasiment la note N°1.
On n'a pas besoin de rajouter une 13ème note,
une 14ème ou les suivantes,
on peut se limiter à 12 notes.
Au lieu de représenter les enchaînements
de quintes en lignes,
on représente ça en cercle, sous forme d'un cycle.
Au bout de 12 quintes, on retombe sur la note N°1,
c'est-à-dire qu'on boucle.
On appelle cette figure, le cycle des quintes.
C'est donc ça qui explique qu'on n'ait
que 12 notes sur un instrument de musique,
les 12 touches du piano ou bien
les 12 frettes de la guitare.
Ce qu'il est important de comprendre, c'est que ce petit
miracle se produit quelle que soit la note de départ.
Là, j'ai choisi 440Hz, mais j'aurais pu prendre
n'importe quoi, ça aurait fonctionné.
Le fait qu'au bout de 12 quintes successives,
on retombe sur la note de départ,
ça vient en fait d'une égalité mathématique.
Quand on prend la quinte, on multiplie
la fréquence par 3/2 et si on fait ça 12 fois de suite,
on retombe sur une fréquence qui est
(3/2)^12 fois la fréquence de départ.
Or, (3/2)^12 si on calcule, ça vaut 129,7
c'est très proche de 128, qui est 2^7
et je vous rappelle, une multiplication par 2,
c'est un passage à l'octave,
donc 2^7, c'est 7 octaves au dessus de la note de départ,
donc prendre 12 fois la quinte,
c'est quasiment comme prendre 7 octaves.
Et du coup, le miracle du fait que le cycle des quintes
boucle au bout de 12 coups,
enfin, boucle presque,
vient d'une presque égalité mathématique,
(3/2)^12 ≈ 2^7
ou autrement dit, 3^12 ≈ 2^19.
Le problème dans cette histoire, c'est le presque,
parce que cette égalité mathématique
n'est pas exactement vraie
et donc le cycle des quintes ne boucle pas exactement,
on ne retombe pas parfaitement sur nos pieds
et ça il va falloir en tenir compte.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Si on se base sur le cycle des quintes pour créer les notes
dont on va avoir besoin pour notre instrument,
on va avoir un petit problème.
Pour créer les fréquences de nos notes on multiplie
à chaque étape par 3/2, ou 3/4 c'est pareil
et on fait ça 11 fois de suite.
Normalement, la quinte de la 12ème note
s'obtient en multipliant à nouveau par 3/2
et devrait valoir 446Hz.
Si on prend la note 1 à la place qui est 440,
ce n'est pas tout à fait la quinte,
c'est-à-dire que cette quinte-là sera un peu trop courte
et on l'obtient en multipliant par 1,48
au lieu de 1,5 c'est-à-dire 3/2.
Au total, si on fait ça, on aura donc 11 quintes
qui seront parfaitement justes
et une qui sera un peu fausse
et il va falloir assumer ça.
Cette manière de déterminer la fréquence
des notes que l'on va utiliser,
donc la façon d'accorder nos instruments,
on l'appelle l'accord Pythagoricien
et donc, on l'a vu, il aura toujours une quinte un peu fausse.
On appelle ça la quinte du loup, ou bien simplement le loup
parce que même pour une oreille pas trop exercée,
elle s'entend vraiment,
elle crée un espèce de battement
qui rappelle le hurlement de l'animal.
Ecoutez par exemple avec un son d'orgue.
Voici d'abord un accord de quinte juste.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Et maintenant un accord de quinte du loup.
Ça fait mal aux oreilles, hein ?
Jusqu'au 15ème siècle, c'est cette manière
d'accorder les instruments qu'on utilisait
et donc tous les instruments avaient un loup.
Sauf qu'on a la liberté de choisir à quel endroit
du cycle des quintes on va mettre le loup
et donc généralement on planquait ça
dans un intervalle qui n'était pas trop utilisé,
du genre, La bémol-Mi bémol,
c'était une manière de cacher un peu la misère.
Mais du coup, pendant toute cette période,
l'obligation d'éviter le loup
restreignait la liberté des instrumentistes
et des compositeurs.
Mais surtout, à part le loup, il y a un autre problème
avec l'accord Pythagoricien
On a vu que naturellement, à cause
de la manière dont vibrent les objets,
si on a une fréquence F, la fréquence 2F
sonne bien avec, c'est l'octave,
ainsi que la fréquence 3F, c'est la quinte.
Pour la même raison, la fréquence 4F sonnera
bien aussi, c'est normal c'est 2 octaves au-dessus.
Mais on peut aller un cran plus loin
et regarder la fréquence 5F,
5F ou bien en descendant d'octave,
la fréquence 5/2F ou 5/4F, c'est pareil,
par rapport à la note de départ, on appelle
cette fréquence la tierce majeure.
Si on prend notre fréquence de base de 440Hz,
la tierce majeure, donc 5/4, sera donc à 550Hz.
Écoutons ce que ça donne.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Ça sonne bien, non ?
A ce stade, on pourrait se dire que ça fait une nouvelle note
qu'il va falloir qu'on rajoute à notre instrument,
à la longue liste de notes qu'on avait déjà.
Mais ce qu'il y a d'amusant, c'est que si on regarde
ce qu'on avait construit avec le cycle des quintes,
on se rend compte que cette fréquence,
on l'avait déjà... enfin presque.
Regardez, après 4 quintes successives
on est tombé sur la fréquence 557Hz,
quasiment la tierce majeure qui est à 550Hz.
A priori, c'est à nouveau quelque chose
d'assez miraculeux,
dans notre construction précédente,
on ne se souciait pas du tout de la tierce,
mais on l'a naturellement fabriquée
en prenant les quintes successives.
La raison pour laquelle ça marche, c'est que multiplier par 5,
est presque égal à multiplier par (3/2)^4, qui vaut 5,06.
Sauf qu'une fois de plus, ça ne tombe pas tout à fait
juste, on a 557Hz alors qu'on voulait 550Hz
et donc, dans le système de l'accord Pythagoricien,
on a bien des tierces, mais qui sont un peu fausses,
qui sont un peu trop larges
et ça s'entend, écoutez.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Le fait que la tierce soit légèrement
fausse dans l'accord Pythagoricien
fait qu'avant le 15ème siècle elle n'était pas
considérée comme un intervalle juste,
du coup, on ne l'utilisait, pour ainsi dire, pas vraiment.
Elles n'ont été considérées comme des consonances
imparfaites que bien plus tardivement.
Il faut dire que dans l'accord Pythagoricien,
la tierce majeure est plus haute que la tierce dite pure.
A cette époque on favorisait les octaves,
les quintes et les quartes,
les intervalles dits parfaits sur lesquels sont basés
l'accord Pythagoricien en somme
et qui forment les premières harmoniques d'un son.
♪ [Chant] ♪
D'ailleurs, fun fact, les intervalles de quinte à vide
sont très régulièrement utilisés dans
les accompagnements dans le rock ou le métal,
on appelle ça un power chord ou un accord
de puissance et ça a une sonorité hyper brute.
♪ [Accords de guitare électrique] ♪
Aux alentours du 15ème siècle, certains musiciens ont
commencé à reconnaître la valeur harmonique de la tierce,
des révisions de la manière d'accorder
les instruments ont très vite suivi.
Donc, dans le système Pythagoricien
basé uniquement sur les quintes,
les tierces sont légèrement fausses,
elles sont un tout petit peu trop grandes.
Une solution pour essayer de corriger ce problème,
c'est de conserver le principe du cycle des quintes,
mais de raccourcir très légèrement toutes les quintes
de manière à ce que les tierces tombent parfaitement juste.
Pour que ça marche, c'est simple, pour passer à la
quinte, au lieu de multiplier par 3/2 qui vaut 1.5,
on va multiplier par 5^(1/4) qui vaut 1.495.
La quinte est quasiment juste,
mais cette fois au bout de 4 quintes,
on a une tierce majeure qui, cette fois, est parfaite.
Cette manière d'accorder les instruments
s'appelle le tempérament mésotonique
et il repose donc sur un compromis, un petit sacrifice,
c'est-à-dire que les quintes deviennent
très légèrement fausses,
mais pour un bénéfice notable,
les tierces deviennent parfaitement justes.
Donc par exemple pour un accord majeur
qui est composé d'une note,
de sa tierce majeure et de sa quinte,
ça passe beaucoup mieux.
♪ [Son d'orgue] ♪
Le seul problème avec le tempérament mésotonique,
c'est qu'on a toujours le problème du loup,
c'est-à-dire que le cycle ne se referme pas tout à fait,
il est même en fait encore plus grave
et même il fausse certaines des tierces
parmi les moins utilisées.
Vers la fin du 15ème siècle, les tempéraments
mésotoniques sont apparus en musique.
A une époque, on a voulu favoriser la tierce,
il a donc fallu trouver un nouveau compromis entre
des tierces justes et des quintes pas trop fausses
et en réalité, il n'existe pas UN tempérament mésotonique,
mais DES tempéraments mésotoniques
qui consistent en différents degrés de justesse
des différents intervalles .
Du fait que les tierces majeures deviennent parfaites
et les quintes légèrement fausses,
cela a, bien sûr, eu un impact sur la manière de composer,
en stimulant l'utilisation des tierces et
en décourageant un peu la quinte à vide
qui était pourtant largement utilisée au moyen âge.
De plus, à cause de la présence de la quinte du loup
et de 4 tierces fausses, les 4 qui passent par le loup,
les compositeurs avaient tendance
à rester dans les mêmes tonalités.
Do, La, Fa, Sol, Si bémol, Ré, pas de problème,
mais les compositeurs évitaient La bémol et Mi bémol
parce que ces tonalités et les triades
correspondantes sonnaient un peu... Meh!
Pour certains, jouer la musique de la renaissance
et les premières musiques baroques
sans utiliser cette manière d'accorder les instruments,
c'est trahir la couleur de la musique
dans l'esprit du compositeur.
A ce stade, on pourrait se demander s'il n'y a pas
un moyen d'avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre,
c'est-à-dire un système où à la fois les quintes
et les tierces seraient parfaitement justes...
on peut essayer.
Pour être concret, je vais revenir aux noms des notes
que l'on connait et je vais vous noter les fréquences.
Imaginons qu'on parte d'un Fa, 352Hz.
On fabrique sa quinte parfaite,
le Do à 528Hz en multipliant par 3/2.
On fabrique aussi sa tierce majeure parfaite,
le La à 440Hz en multipliant par 5/4.
Puis en prenant, soit la tierce parfaite du Do,
soit la quinte du La, on tombe sur le Mi,
jusqu'ici tout va bien, tout est parfaitement juste.
En prenant la quinte du Do, on tombe
sur le Sol, la tierce du Sol, c'est le Si
qu'on obtient aussi comme quinte du Mi
et la quinte du Sol, c'est le Ré.
Vous voyez qu'on a fabriqué les 7 notes
de la gamme de Do majeur
sans faire aucune approximation et aucun compromis.
A ce stade il faudrait encore rajouter les dièses et les bémols,
mais même sans aller jusque là,
en fait on a déjà un problème.
J'ai créé ces notes de la gamme de Do, mais maintenant,
imaginez que je veuille jouer en gamme de Ré.
Pour jouer en Ré, je peux partir de celui-ci, je l'ai.
Je vais avoir besoin de sa quinte et normalement c'est le La.
On pourrait se dire qu'on l'a déjà ici...
Mais le problème, c'est que ce La là
n'est pas la quinte parfaite du Ré,
c'est la tierce parfaite du Fa,
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait la même chose.
Celui-ci s'obtient en prenant une tierce à partir du Fa
et celui-là, 4 quintes à partir du Fa
et une tierce parfaite ou 4 quintes parfaites,
on l'a vu, ce n'est pas tout à fait pareil.
En bref, même si on arrive à accorder notre instrument
parfaitement pour jouer en gamme de Do,
dès qu'on veut changer de gamme, on est coincés.
Cette manière d'accorder les instruments,
on l'appelle parfois "juste" ou "naturelle",
ou bien "l'accordage des physiciens".
Le problème, c'est qu'on ne peut pas transposer
la musique ou jouer dans des gammes différentes,
à moins de changer d'accordage
à chaque fois qu'on change de tonalité.
La raison pour laquelle ça ne peut pas marcher
est la même que pour le cycle des quintes,
on a un problème de bouclage.
La différence c'est qu'ici, on fabrique des notes
en utilisant à la fois la quinte et la tierce,
donc on ne fait plus une ligne,
comme dans le cycle des quintes,
mais un réseau de notes en 2 dimensions,
on appelle ça parfois le tonnetz.
Le tonnetz que, techniquement, on voudrait refermer
non pas en cercle, mais sous forme d'un tore,
ne se referme pas parfaitement,
de même que le cycle des quintes
ne bouclait pas parfaitement.
Petite remarque au passage, ce qu'on vient de raconter là,
c'est vrai pour les instruments qui ont
un accordage fixe comme un piano ou une guitare,
mais sur un instrument qui peut jouer
toutes les fréquences continûment,
l'instrumentiste a la liberté de jouer différemment
une certaine note suivant la gamme dans laquelle on joue.
C'est vrai par exemple pour les cordes
ou bien le trombone à coulisse,
mais c'est aussi particulièrement vrai pour le chant.
Un chanteur ou une chanteuse qui en a la maîtrise technique
peut choisir de chanter très légèrement différemment
un La, suivant qu'il apparaît par exemple comme
la tierce du Fa, dans un accord de Fa majeur,
ou bien comme la quinte du Ré.
Bon, maintenant on va essayer de voir quelle est
la solution moderne à tous ces problèmes d'accordages.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Ce qu'il faut bien réaliser, c'est que tous ces petits
problèmes qu'on a pour accorder les instruments
ne peuvent pas avoir de solution parfaite,
c'est lié à l'arithmétique,
3^12 ce n'est pas exactement 2^19
et (3/2)^4 ce n'est pas exactement 5,
donc de toute façon, on aura toujours un souci.
On ne peut pas accorder un instrument de manière
à ce que tout soit toujours juste dans toutes les gammes,
c'est mort.
Mais ce qu'on peut faire, c'est essayer
de répartir un peu le désaccord
de manière à ce que tout soit à peu près correct.
La solution moderne qu'on utilise aujourd'hui,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le tempérament égal
et ça consiste à répartir le désaccord
de manière homogène sur toutes les notes
de manière à ce que ça ne s'entende pas trop.
Voilà comment on fait.
On sait qu'avec, par exemple, l'accord Pythagoricien,
entre une note et son octave,
on trouve 12 notes intermédiaires
et bien on va simplement décider que
pour passer d'une note à la suivante,
on multiplie toujours par 2^(1/12)
et du coup au bout de 12 coups, on retombe pile sur l'octave.
Et on trouve des valeurs qui sont
assez proches de celles qu'on avait avant,
la quinte s'obtient au bout de 7 coups et vaut 2^(7/12)
qui est 1.498 donc vraiment très proche de 3/2.
La tierce s'obtient au bout de 5 coups
et vaut 2^(5/12) qui est 1.26,
soit assez proche de 5/4.
En répartissant le désaccord sur tous les intervalles,
on arrive à cacher la misère
et à éviter, par exemple, les problèmes de loup.
Dans le fond, à part l'octave,
tous les intervalles sont très légèrement faux,
mais de manière parfaitement uniforme
et en plus, toutes les tonalités se valent
et sont traitées à la même enseigne.
Le fait que toutes les tonalités soient utilisables
est notamment ce que Jean-Sébastien Bach a essayé
de démontrer dans son "Clavier Bien Tempéré"
qui est un véritable terrain de jeu,
puisqu'il y compose 2 pièces
dans chacune des tonalités possibles.
♪ [Piano] ♪
Mais contrairement à ce qu'on entend souvent,
Bach n'utilisait pas le tempérament égal
qui est une invention plus récente,
mais une manière d'accorder
les instruments extrêmement proche,
probablement l'une de celles inventées
par un de ses contemporains: Werkmeister.
Le tempérament de Werkmeister essaie lui aussi
de répartir la dissonance sur tous les intervalles,
mais pas de manière homogène.
Dans ce tempérament, toutes les tonalités sonnent bien,
mais elles ne sonnent pas toutes exactement pareil
comme dans le tempérament égal
et c'est notamment l'esprit du "Clavier Bien Tempéré"
composé de préludes et de fugues
dans les 12 tonalités majeures
et les 12 tonalités mineures.
Si on joue ces œuvres avec
un tempérament de Werkmeister,
cela fait ressortir les différentes colorations
spécifiques de chaque tonalité.
Ces légères colorations disparaissent à partir
du moment où on joue avec un tempérament égal,
dans la mesure où toutes les tonalités se valent.
Il est important d'insister sur une chose,
il sera probablement toujours question de compromis
pour avoir la plus grande liberté compositionnelle.
Le tempérament égal est de loin
le pire des tempéraments de tous,
dans la mesure où il ne comporte aucun intervalle juste,
à l'exception de l'octave, bien sûr.
Mais c'est également le meilleur, puisqu'il
ne comporte aucun intervalle terriblement faux.
Aujourd'hui, sauf exception,
l'accordage par tempérament égal
est la méthode qu'on utilise
pour accorder tous les instruments,
du moins dans la musique occidentale traditionnelle.
En fait, il y a plein d'autres manières de faire
qui ont été explorées par certains compositeurs
ou bien dans certaines régions du monde.
La musique arabe, par exemple,
utilise fréquemment 24 notes au lieu de 12
en divisant simplement chaque intervalle
en 2 pour créer des quarts de ton.
♪ [Musique] ♪
La musique indienne en utilise 22 qu'on appelle les shrutis.
♪ [Musique indienne] ♪
Il existe aussi d'autres manières de diviser l'octave,
par exemple en 19 notes au lieu de 12.
Un système comme cela traite différemment
les dièses et les bémols
et donc par exemple, contrairement à ce qu'on a sur un piano,
un Ré dièse serait traité différemment d'un Mi bémol.
Certains compositeurs contemporains comme
Joel Mandelbaum, Joseph Yasser ou Ivor Darreg
ont écrit des pièces pour ce type de musique.
Ecoutez la sonorité de ce morceau.
♪ [Musique] ♪
Et on pourrait pousser encore plus loin, par exemple,
en divisant l'octave en 31 ou 53 intervalles.
Toutes ces manières de faire font partie
de ce qu'on appelle la musique microtonale,
c'est-à-dire la musique qui utilise des intervalles
qui sont plus petits que les 12 demi tons habituels.
Ça reste un style assez marginal, mais il arrive parfois
que ça soit utilisé dans la musique populaire.
Ecoutez par exemple l'introduction
de ce morceau de Radiohead.
Je trouve que ça donne une sacrée ambiance au morceau.
En tout cas, merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
Merci beaucoup à Vled qui m'a fait le plaisir de venir m'aider
et vous pouvez bien sûr aller
vous abonner à sa chaîne "Le Set Barré"
et vous pouvez aussi le retrouver sur "La tronche en biais".
Si vous voulez avoir les actus de la chaîne,
vous pouvez les retrouver sur Facebook et sur Twitter
et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci, à bientôt!